probably the closest thing we'd ever get  to a real-life lightsaber would be one  with a super hot plasma blade held  together by a strong electromagnetic  field powered by a microscopic  antimatter power source  wait what a lightsaber is a beam of  contained Plasma in the Star Wars  universe that is contained using the  force in actual physics Labs we contain  plasmas using large electromagnetic  fields and nobody has been able to  contain a plasma in a small beam like a  lightsaber but you know maybe someday  we'd be able to so a lightsaber blade  would be made of super hot plasma that  can expand and retract within a given  area and this area would be surrounded  by a strong electromagnetic field that  holds the plasma together this type of  magnetic field would even allow for  actual lightsaber duels or for  deflecting Blaster bolts since the  magnetic fields of each lightsaber or  bolt would just bounce right off one  another